[Music]
over the past eight years we have seen
the Dark Knight appear in many film
incarnations I'm a huge Batman fan and
have great admiration for the character
and all of the cinematic appearances
that he is made to celebrate the release
of Justice League I decided to write the
Batman films from worst to best from
1966 onwards whilst there are two films
released before the 66 version they're
difficult to recommend you of the
limitations of the time Batman truly
became a phenomenon on screen due to
Adam West and Burt Ward's depiction so I
will be counting from this point forward
without the way let's dive into my list
of all the Batman movies ranked from
1966 to Justice League
well it's not being outright terrible
Batman Forever
isn't spectacular either introducing a
new Dark Knight in director the film
feels like a toned down version of the
Burton verse that preceded it
featuring an uncharacteristically bad
Tommy Lee Jones performance the film
suffers from poor pacing a weak love
subplot and lots and lots of neon lights
don't forget the bat nipples which were
absolutely terrible the film just isn't
funny either
even with Jim Carrey at the helm it
could have done with some humor and
that's why our next entry places
slightly above it my name is freeze
was a chilling sound of your do look yes
I know people are probably gonna be mad
at this place too both Batman Forever
but Batman and Robin is so bad it's good
featuring more ice puns than a vanilla
ice ice tea and Ice Cube collaboration
track this film has its tongue placed
firmly in its cheek at the time it was
criticized for revitalizing the 1966
camp version of the character but this
movie can be looked back as showcasing
the potential of the Dark Knight as a
character the Caped Crusader can either
be a dark and brooding figure or a fun
and comedic one providing more
entertainment than Batman Forever Batman
and Robin secures the second-to-last
place on our list
[Music]
there's no doubt that Suicide Squad
suffered from studio interference
promoting the Joker heavily the film had
confusing marketing externally and poor
characterization internally it's
difficult even to say who the main
character is and sloppy editing makes
the movie almost unwatchable at certain
points whilst Batman's featured very
little his brief appearances are
certainly highlights within the film
that had a wealth of exposition of
Gotham never before had we seen Batman
appear out of the blue and asked war
criminals to Arkham like this and it
certainly is one of the most memorable
moments of the movie Adam West and Burt
Ward gave iconic performances as the
dynamic duo what was great about the
1966 show is that as a kid II thought it
was the most serious thing in the world
this perspective change as you grew into
adulthood and realize how hilarious it
was with memorable scenes such as some
days you're just yet this movie is let
down you a budget constraints and age
but it's still a great watch for diehard
fans that's how it starts
whilst drowning in problems theatrically
the extended edition remedies many of
the nonsensical aspects of the film sure
Batman V Superman suffers from a weak
villain the scene and the serial killer
in the cape and cowl but there's still a
lot to like for die-hard fans this movie
is a cinematic milestone through its
depiction of the first time at The Dark
Knight and the Man of Steel met on the
silver screen bring to life the work of
Frank Miller and showcasing what is by
far the best fight scene in a Batman
movie to date Batman V Superman gave us
one of the most iconic depictions of the
Caped Crusader
Oh Justice League the latest entry on
our list unfortunately suffers from a
weak narrative lackluster villain and
mediocre CGI that's not to say it's bad
perfectly capturing the essence of
Justice League Unlimited the film
depicts a mature er wise a Batman that
feels like a fully fleshed personality
instead of merely an archetype aided by
Elfman's iconic score batman becomes a
leader
realizing that he works better with
others as opposed to by himself a far
cry from the darker and angrier version
of the character in Batman V Superman
Ben Affleck feels like he is fully grown
into the role and provides a brilliant
foundation for the rest of the team to
springboard off while it's not perfect
this film still encapsulate many of the
fantasies that fans had about the team's
first onscreen ensemble and feels like a
step in the right direction bettering
many of the flaws from its predecessor
in the DC Universe perhaps the
inevitable extended cut will save the
movie but for now it ranks in just
behind Batman Returns
Batman Returns is a mixed bag ranging
from cool to absurd this film seems like
a twisted nightmare at points featuring
a demonic penguin that gropes in Lea's
over women all whilst ruling black slime
it's not hard to see why parents didn't
want their kids seeing this movie aging
poorly it's obvious that Burton was more
interested in the villains than he was
in the cake crusader and the central
character feels bland and boring this is
more Edward Scissorhands than Batman and
because of this it ranks lower on our
list than its predecessor action just go
ahead when you're ready sorry I wasn't
listening I've just been bat mailing on
my bad phone yeah can you just do the
one relying heavily on Batman the lego
movie showcases the Dark Knight as a
parody launching batarangs by the second
the satirical look at the character
provides a wealth of jokes on his 75
year history and at the time it was one
of the most unique depictions of the
Dark Knight don't overlook this because
you think it might be too kitty this is
definitely one for the die-hard fans you
are as precious to me as you were to
your own mother and father I swore to
him that I would protect you and I
happened to you - it's amazing opening
and phenomenal final act The Dark Knight
Rises elevates Nolan's trilogy to the
best comic book movie collection to date
featuring the redemption of the Dark
Knight we see Gotham fall to its lowest
point and learn the value of symbols
Dark Knight Rises just misses out due to
some lackluster plot elements and poor
villain characterization the Lego Batman
movie was a risk however it paid off
massively as hilarious as it is gorgeous
to watch Lego Batman sense of the
character
in a roast like fashion at its heart has
great care for the icon and that's why
it works well for newcomers and old fans
alike featuring my new Easter eggs such
as Billy Dee Williams as to face and the
condiment King costume there's enough
year to keep fans coming back for more
Lego Batman is a triumph Batman Begins
start a new trend for comic book movies
presenting a grittier realistic Batman
this film focused on the psychology of
fear and what motives would possess
someone to become a vigilante a far cry
from what I'd come before Batman Begins
legacy still can be seen today
influencing hundreds of films it secures
itself within the top 5 Batman 1989 was
a phenomenon upon release revitalizing
comic book films it bounced perfectly
the dark and brooding Batman with the
camp lighthearted one beautiful in its
aesthetic the costumes car and
characters have a timeless feel to them
Jack Nicholson nails the Joker and tears
at the scenery every time he graces the
screen Michael Keaton expertly depicts
the trouble persona of Bruce Wayne and
the film's score elevates this movie to
the level of unforgettable blockbuster
this film in my opinion is timeless and
you really need to go back and re-watch
it if you haven't seen it for a while
it's absolutely great
I like the Cape not sure about the mask
that man mask of the phantasm expertly
captures the dark and brooding tone of
the Cape crusader featuring stellar
performances by Kevin Conroy and Mark
Hamill the film tells the tale of Bruce
Wayne's first love
at heart the pieces of mystery one that
has a shocking conclusion and cements
the reason why Batman has to continue on
his never-ending journey to end crime
heavily influenced by year one his
picture contains the definitive version
of The Dark Knight and rightfully earns
its spot at number two
the dark night still reigns is the
greatest comic book movie ever made
revolutionising the genre the film was
the first of its kind to win an Oscar
feeling like a crime film as opposed to
a comic book story the movie features
iconic performances from all of its cast
most notably Heath Ledger The Dark
Knight takes all of the boxes
Bernsen drama with dark humor it packs a
real punch on every level showcasing the
fall of Harvey Dent
we are trekked to a movie that features
expanse of metaphors on the Iraq war and
economic game theory influencing all
that followed the dark nights shaped the
landscape for comic-book movies and its
influence is still seen today across the
board as good today as it was upon
release the Dark Knight secures the
number one spot on our Batman movie list
[Music]
from worst to best
did you agree have you seen Justice
League and if so what did you think
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video I'd really appreciate
it if you subscribed and liked it also
check out my dog Knight Returns series
in which I read through the series
chronologically from The Last Crusade
all the way to Dark Knight 3 the master
race thanks very much for checking out
this video and take care